invisible mais indispensable à toute
forme de vie l'air s'installe au coeur
d'une exposition sur l'île de loisirs de
saint quentin en yvelines le climat la
respiration ou encore les odeurs
plusieurs thématiques sont abordées pour
comprendre l'interaction entre l'homme
et l'air une exposition aussi
pédagogique interactive les yvelines
sont la dernière étape d'un voyage
débuter en 2016 et qui a parcouru toute
l'île de france
cette exposition elle n'est pas figée au
fur et à mesure des deux mois
d'installation
on espère je pense que ça devrait bien
arriver que les gens qui vont visiter
vont avoir envie de participer et de
s'exprimer
à l'intérieur de cette exposition
soutenue notamment par la région
l'exposition a déjà été visitée par
quarante mille personnes depuis un an et
demi
ce jour-là à lille de loisirs de saint
quentin en yvelines l'atelier pour les
enfants est consacrée aux cerfs-volants
s'il n'y a pas de vins le cerf-volant va
toujours rester par terre et il ne va
pas voler alors que le vent il va tenir
le cerf-volant
dans les airs et puis ça va voler ça va
bouger
r l'expo qui inspire est à découvrir
jusqu'au 30 juillet à saint quentin en
yvelines et dimanche prochain une après
midi spécial sera consacré au
réchauffement climatique